foreign
hey what's going on it's Monday once
again time for Ghost Stories [__] like
that yeah
I gotta get warmed up yeah yeah get your
[__] together time I'm getting it
together
eat more alcohol yeah try to jump start
this [__] been [__] working on bikes
all day
oh yeah that's right I forgot you had to
do all that sprayed that
Plasti Dip rubber coating all over the
frame so now it's rubber coated thick
too
cool yeah I didn't want to paint first I
want to try what a rubber coating would
do for it first we'll see because I got
a rubber in other places
and it's held up for years
yeah nothing about is you just pull it
off yeah you know what I mean it's not
stuck to it really you just pull it off
with a big sheet if you don't like it
okay I've got talking about some cooking
shows yeah talking about like uh and
also a very nice sounding set of knives
that he bought today 99 bucks that's not
bad though for a six yeah with six Knife
Set yeah that would be good ones that
would be it that would be like a decent
inexpensive set yeah
a [__] really good set especially
something that was like specialized for
for sushi and [__] like cutting Sushi
and crap like that a grand
easy yeah they got [__] knife sets
out there but it's like a scalpel and
[__] you can have something real
delicate that would normally just Mash
that she'll just go through it like a
laser
it's like it's like a surgical scalpel
one even [__] wouldn't even bend the
sushi roll you know see I'd be scared to
death to use and I was like that because
I just cut all my fingers off yeah yeah
the first day easily and I'd be like
well
guess I didn't need those fingers yeah
you gotta be careful you gotta have good
knife skills and you know how clutzy I
am so you know what I mean I I just
would rather not
you know next Dimension media says hi
Jenny wondering if you started using any
AI tools for your job only asking
because I've been doing a deep dive into
various AI Graphics tools lately I have
actually started using AI for not at you
know my job job but um I'm actually
experimenting with it for a new board
game that I want to do uh and it's
actually coming out pretty cool like I
you know I just kind of I use a Dream by
Wombo which you know I just picked one I
guess they're all kind of similar but
the nice thing about Dream by Wombo is
that it has um like a whole bunch of
different filters and they add new
filters like pretty much every week it
looks like I have the app on my phone
and I use it on the desktop as well but
yeah that's mainly what I've been using
it for and sometimes I use it for you
know for if I'm doing like uh poster art
like for momentum Ori or something like
that like I'll see what if what it comes
up with like if it comes up with
something cool looking but yeah
sometimes it comes up with some really
and they added they finally added like
three horror filters which I was like
yeah it took you guys long enough
because they had like some sci-fi ones
and like some steampunk ones and like
some synthwave ones but I was like why
don't you guys have any horror filters
but they had one called spectral but
it's always
and it's cool but it's like um it's
always like buildings you know I mean
like creepy old houses and stuff like
that really no matter what prompt you
put in which I'm like well that's not
that useful but the horror ones are good
and actually it seems like it's getting
better but sometimes you I still put in
a phrase and then it comes up with
something like what the where the [__]
did you get that from like that's
nothing like what I said but okay so
it's not perfect obviously because
sometimes I can't get what I want you
know what I mean and it takes a really
long time
um let's see uh Zach says my mid-journey
is it mid Journey or my journey I can't
really see is the best art generator
it's subscription but only ten dollars a
month for the basic plan yeah there's a
lot of really good ones I've heard but
like I said I've just been using Dream
by Longboat because that was kind of the
first one I came up with I'm like oh
this one's neat so
I mean I might experiment with some
other ones like going down the line but
I don't use it that much like I said I'm
just kind of thinking about like a board
game that I want to do
and I want to use it for like the cards
you know that's all
so uh yeah how are you doing over there
Tom is the alcohol bleaching in
It's not taking I'm good it's not taking
effect yet
okay
so this episode right here that we're
talking about and oh and I have to say
too that this week is going to be like a
whole paranormal palooza because not
only are we doing The Haunting show
today like we usually do but on
Wednesday our main show is also going to
be paranormal and it's a case that I've
been wanting to talk about for a while
it's the Ammons haunting yeah which I
actually wrote about in my book The
Unseen hand like a long time ago and
this is the one that um Zach see I keep
saying Baggins but I'm pretty sure that
he said Bagans Bagans yeah and I was
like Oh I thought I want to say Baggins
I thought his bag is like
[Laughter]
so so we actually last night we actually
watched the documentary that Zach
Biggins made about the Ammons house yeah
which he bought but you know we'll save
most of that for Wednesday but it's a
fascinating case some didn't really know
much about it that was that was Amazon
yeah it was it was on Amazon Prime if
you have if you have an Amazon Prime
subscription you can watch it on there
what's the name of that you remember
demon house yeah it was interesting
because it was it was like a documentary
and it had the uh the actual Witnesses
yeah it's taking place in Gary and
Indiana
you know I've lived in Detroit for a
couple years and Gary is looking a
little bit to the West there
it's a [__] it's a post-apocalyptic
[__] place you know it's falling
apart
not as bad as Detroit Detroit's almost
gone now but the witnesses to it were
the are the most interesting part of the
case
the Baggins I wouldn't I wouldn't trust
but he's a flim-flam guy man [__] it
he's gonna come off later he comes off
his uh [__] trying to put on a big
show
but the the Witnesses are kind of some
of them are compelling some of them are
some of them want muddy for their
testimony I'll tell you anything kind of
deal how'd you gonna pay me
but I think something happened there I
think it was Poltergeist though
yeah it is what it was because it
involved kids
Camp guy said they got a new sandwich at
Publix chicken bacon smoked gouda with
barbecue sauce tomatoes onions lettuce
Etc I don't remember what they called it
but it was new and on sale that actually
does sound really good yeah it sounds
good every time I go though I always
kind of I'm like oh maybe I'll get
something else but I always end up
getting that wrist you can get it in
foot yeah you can probably get them all
you can get them all in foot long
and I like like around Thanksgiving they
have that like that Thanksgiving so for
a little while that's also delicious
yeah we're gonna have to go get some
more turkeys day after Thanksgiving go
down there and buy five turkeys
we still have something last year I got
four turkeys yeah
oh maybe we should make it I just slow
cook them yeah they're good put some uh
cover them up and put some uh what do
you call it uh Liquid Smoke on them
don't even stuff them
just like a little smoked turkey kind of
thing it's good just make sandwiches and
just eat it read it right off the bone
also Dave is here saying hello to you
both hey what's going on popped in to
say hey yeah sorry we haven't been in
mannequins for the last few weeks but
you know
we just haven't we haven't been out
anywhere really Dave got a tent a
tribute tattoo of Kaylee on his arm I
saw that yeah it's yeah it's cool
yeah yeah we were talking about her the
other day
Katie was our little daughter a little
lesbian daughter that died of [__]
cancer yeah we called her our daughter
we hung out with him yeah yeah we've
talked about her before what was that
yeah
um yeah it was really sucks they found
it too late it was ate her up yeah and
she was young too really young she's 30
maybe 31. I think she was 34 34. okay
she looked like a little kid she was
only
what maybe four eleven yeah little
Texican girl
yep
Zach says also hooray I gave myself a
haircut and it doesn't look awful all
right good for you
[Laughter]
and then Camp guys then says about the
sandwiches I usually get the Italian all
the way but this one was like 7.99 promo
for a 12 inch wow that's a good deal
I'm gonna have to try that well I say
I'm gonna try that out but then when I
get down there I'm like oh the roast
beef it's so good
and then he says I like my sub like I
like my women all the way with heavy
onions and banana peppers
you do you man
all right yeah jeffreyard said you gave
me an idea for lunch tomorrow
all right so um so like I said the the
Ammons haunting house that's what we're
going to talk about on Wednesday night's
show like the main show but on this
evening show we are talking about season
seven of a haunting episode three I
think it was episode three
um and we skipped a couple episodes
because we already did some season seven
ones like a while back so this is the
first one in season seven that we hadn't
done yet and it was called demon
Unearthed even though I kept wanting to
say demon Unleashed but that's because
there was another episode called the
Unleashed that we already did so I was
confusing both of them see so like I
said it's that [__]
it's the Bingo it's the word Bingo that
they use where they just keep pulling
the words out of the hat and like
putting them together so demon Unearthed
which actually does
sort of play into the actual story kind
of
so as I mentioned uh this takes place in
Garden Grove Iowa oh I don't think I did
mention that that's where it takes place
Garden Grove Iowa
and I think this happened like in the
early 2000s or like it started out in
the early 2000s
so you have the rice family the dad is
Norman the mom is Jennifer and they have
a son named Andrew who he he's grown up
now obviously and he was on the show but
he was saying that he was about eight or
nine at this time
so they see this old Victorian Mansion
um and they've wanted it for a long time
and they finally you know get a chance
to buy it now this was built they said
it was built at the turn of the century
Century so I'm assuming you know 1900.
by some kind of famous Rich businessman
in town now apparently Garden Grove Iowa
which I didn't know this but this was
kind of a major city at the turn of the
century because like there was a big
railroad Hub I guess
so um it's spoiler alert it's not a
major city anymore but it used to be
so Jennifer is super Jazz about buying
this house because she felt like it
belonged to her and she was the one that
was supposed to fix it all up and all
this other kind of stuff I'm like if you
ever feel that way about a house I'm not
really sure that's a good thing because
that's how a lot of horror stories start
I'm just saying
so the first thing that happens is that
they're there and you know they're doing
the whole thing and the kid's like wow
we're gonna live here it's so big and
blah blah so um so they do that and then
he looks up in the upper window and sees
like a real creepy [__] ghosty dude
obviously like looking out the upper
window like with a [__] it was like a
derby or something Derby kind of hat
now I was confused at first because they
showed this in the reenactment but he
didn't say that he'd seen that but then
like later on in the show he did say
that he had seen the guy in the window
so I guess they didn't mention it at the
time like that they showed it in the
reenactment but they did mention it
later so because I was sitting there
going well did he really see that
because he didn't say that [__] but yeah
so he saw like a creepy dude like up in
the window and was like huh I wonder
what that's about
now at this point the narrator says you
know at this house an unspeakable horror
took place and even though it's
unspeakable they're gonna tell you what
it is anyway so which is funny because I
was like okay
um apparently according to rumor in town
the guy I guess it was the guy the
businessman who built the house right
apparently allegedly he had had an
affair with one of the maids or like one
of the servants that in the house
and got her pregnant
and then
um he obviously couldn't have that
getting around because it would ruin his
reputation everything like that so
supposedly she sort of like accidentally
on purpose
fell down the stairs and then he
supposedly buried her in the basement
that was what how the story went anyway
I don't know if that's actually true or
not but that was what everybody in town
like thought happened at that house
right so I guess like the house had been
empty for a while and partially I'm
supposing because of those rumors about
it
so the rice family move in though and
they're planning on spending quite a bit
of money to fix it all up even though
this scene was like actually kind of
hilarious to me because Norman
the husband
um he's like because because Jennifer is
just like all Starry Eyed and she's like
oh my God we're gonna like restore it
just the way it was and blah blah and
he's just like yeah do what you want
honey but don't go crazy okay so please
don't spend all my money you know what I
mean he was kind of going like that
she's like no no we have to do it
exactly right and he's like oh [__] me
this was a mistake but yeah so it was
kind of like that now here's what I
thought was kind of weird
is that this house that they're moving
into is in Iowa
Norman the dad is a software engineer or
something like that he works in Arizona
which is like more than a thousand miles
away
so he's gone for like I mean I guess
it's be similar to them being like a
truck driver or something like that but
he's gone for like months at a time
because you're not going to go back and
forth from [__] Arizona to Iowa just
to see your damn family it must be
building something it's construction bro
yeah I guess he was like a contractor or
something well he does he did software
they software they said
and what year was this early 2000s
so he they couldn't remote work
makes me wonder see I'm thinking it was
just due to [__] security contractor
yeah maybe he's out there working on
those missile ranges
you know yeah
he'd be down there for a long time it's
like you know it's like being in the
military
yeah I guess so or be like working on an
oil rig or something like you'd be gone
for months at a time you're like a month
on and like a week off and a month on
and a week off that kind of [__] I guess
I just always thought that one month off
I guess it's not that weird all right
maybe some people do I get I guess it's
weird to us because like we're together
all the time yeah so it'd be really
strange no some dudes leave yeah I know
I mean I think some of that oil rig work
was a month out there and a month back
yeah that's what I heard a month back
right and those dudes got big houses and
nice wives and [__] and I guess you
gotta trust them yeah they got kids you
know a lot of them and uh but you know
they're making
at least 100 Grand a year yeah out there
on that damn oil rig
if they're up to an underwater welding
it's like several hundred thousand
dollars well I hope they pay those
people well because that is a very very
deal yeah those dudes professional those
dudes are so they'll wake your ass up at
[__] three o'clock in the morning you
gotta get down though we'll get in the
water and go fix some [__] at three in
the morning yeah no thank you [__]
thousand feet underneath the water yeah
with the whales and the [__] [__]
giant [__] squid right that's like a
flashlight in a [__] total darkness
yeah even one other dude thank you
trying to weld this piece of [__] that's
like one of my worst years so yeah I
don't even want to know what's down
there it's a man's job right there man
that's a it better be a man's paycheck
too like I said they better be paying
those people a lot holy [__] that's
horrifying yeah because a lot of people
wouldn't do it and I don't blame them
hell no I wouldn't do it [__] that I'm I
do not like deep water man me neither I
mean not at all used to you know
snorkeling [__] off the Gulf of Aqaba
you know when we were when we were in
Egypt and it was clear blue water you
could see all the way down the bottom
you had good visibility uh on right
outside that Reef you'd see big fish and
following you and [__] and it was nice
because you could see far yeah but no in
the Deep blackness
with a flashlight absolutely not and you
[__] Shine the Light down you can't
see the bottom uh-uh you're basically
flying over you're basically flying and
you're flying over a mountain range for
all you know as high as a jet would be
off the ground ah no thanks anything
they could just swim up and grab you
something huge well that's what I'm
saying it's like that's I have I've had
nightmares ever since I was a kid of
like being like really deep underwater
and then like like I said like all you
have is a flashlight or some [__] like
that you go like that and there's a big
[__] shark like right there like
right in your face like hey get a
munchie now or you're shying a light
around and the beam just goes out into
Infinity kind of just Fades away you
know and then you hit something or
something big there you know oh [__]
yeah and it's like even if it was far it
would scare me well yeah I mean 100 you
know if it was 50 yards away underneath
the water and I could make it out and
it's just like a big ass [__] squid
or a huge big eye watch or some [__]
like that oh [__] we gotta go big ass
Humboldt squid you know maybe I have a
hard time imagine like watching movies
or [__] like that in it that just like
gives me really bad anxiety yeah that's
one of the worst things like hot boats
will kill you they're not that big but
they're they're big enough to kill you
yeah size of a large dog and they
[__] run around in packs and they're
intelligent they don't live longer
they're dumb as [__] uh that's funny
they're intelligent but they're dumb
um they're they got an octopus as
intelligence but they're not very old
and they're filled with [__]
testosterone they [__] grow real
quickly and they only live like about a
year or so and they're cut and because
of that they're ravenously hungry all
the time and if their buddy [__] gets
wounded they turn on them and eat him
and then they'll go back to trying to
eat you [__] dangerous things man
humble
Camp guy said I've heard of dudes that
got sucked down inside a hole in the
bottom of the ocean
yeah what's up uh yeah big time so yeah
I'm just gonna try and stay as far away
from the ocean as possible I mean like I
said I was born in Daytona which is
right on the ocean if you didn't know
that and uh so I certainly went into the
Atlantic Ocean a lot of times when I was
a kid but I never really liked it
because my mom loved the beach so she
would take it there all the time but I
was just kind of like I had like little
sharks go up against my legs and stuff
and I'm just like nope not for me no
thank you I've been out in fishing boats
in the Gulf of Mexico my dad and his
buddies this is back in the [__] 80s
when I was a kid
seasick is a [__] even though
Uncle Punch's daughter was there
I was probably about 14 she's about 16
in a bikini she's hot as [__] just
[__] up laid up there on the top I
was still just throwing up and puking
the whole time I was embarrassed as hell
and she came down there and gave me a
Nutty butter Nutter buddy you know what
do you call them a little [__] Little
Debbie cake and she goes that here throw
that up it'll feel good that's what she
[__] told me [__] funny here it'll
taste just it's good coming back up
again and uh never a fan of the water
man no me neither no like I said every
time we watch that show like I shouldn't
be alive or something like that like
every time there's one where the people
get stranded out in the middle of the
ocean we're just like oh let's never go
on the ocean yeah there's too much [__]
that can go wrong out there oh thank you
too much [__] that could go wrong
and uh people too far away to help you
if you need help right away yeah
if you went out there and [__] with
fishing and lost a limb or something you
probably wouldn't make it back nope by
the time they got to you you'd be gone
I don't know sometimes I think it's like
I'd rather go to the Moon than go out
there you know what I mean I don't know
about that I don't want to go to the
Moon either I'm just saying that if
somebody like made me choose I'm not
really sure not really sure I think I'd
rather go to space I'd rather go to
space space doesn't scare me as much you
can I mean space scares me too but I
think it was a vacuum but I think the
ocean scares me worse you get killed by
the vacuum if you [__] it the spacecraft
gets [__] compromised but it's not as
scary as [__] drowning
vacuum and kill you pretty quick before
like I said getting your leg bit off by
yeah
no thank you at least you had a good
view on your way out yeah I died in
space [__]
you know yeah at least it's a badass
right yeah yeah
all right so uh how do we get distracted
like that okay oh so we were talking
about the guy yeah they live in Iowa and
yet he works in Arizona so he's gone all
the time like I said it really does seem
like and I don't know why that is I
don't know if they just choose stories
that are like that because it makes the
rest of the family seem more vulnerable
but it does seem that I don't know what
the percentage is but I'm gonna say 90
of the episodes of Haunting always have
the dad it's either like a single mom
and kids or it's a family that has a dad
but the dad like always works the night
shift or he's like a truck driver or
he's gone all the time or something like
that like so he's there's just some
reason why he's not there all the time
and I just wonder if they do that on
purpose so yeah so this guy is gone I
think he's he seems like he's gone for
like months at a time right like working
in Arizona so Jennifer basically is
obliged to sort of like work restoring
the house by herself which she doesn't
really mind because she did want to do
it but you know what I mean now she does
have a little team of contractors uh the
main contractor's name is Claude and um
so they're all there working on the
house now there was a incident where
Claude I guess he was putting in a
chandelier like in the dining room or
whatever and he's on the ladder and
according to him I guess the latter
started shaking so much that like like
that and then like he fell off of it and
he said that he was pushed off
and uh Jennifer said that he was like
super super nervous and he's just like
yeah I gotta go I don't want to be in
this [__] house anymore and he took
off
now Jennifer said that she also
overheard a couple of the other workers
talking about
um don't you know what happened in this
house and it's like we're not I'm not
going down in the basement [__] that
[__] like stuff like that and then they
then they told the story about yeah the
the guy that built the house like he
knocked up a servant and like then
killed her and buried her down there and
he's like I'm not going down there [__]
that you know what I mean
now Andrew the son he was about eight or
nine as I said he actually overheard
this conversation too and it's like even
though he was creeped out by this like
ooh holy [__] there might be a lady like
buried down in the basement he's also
you know he's like a kid so he's just
kind of like me I'm gonna go check that
[__] out so apparently he goes down into
the basement and the light on the wall
starts flickering and [__] like that and
then he said that he felt like when he
was down there he said it felt like
somebody dropped a ton of bricks on me
like that's what he said that he felt
like really heavy and then when he's
down there he said he felt what felt
like a skeleton hand grabbing him by the
ankle like coming out of the dirt and
like grabbing him by the ankle I don't
know if that was his imagination because
he had just heard about somebody being
buried down there or what but he said he
did feel like it what felt like a
skeleton hand so uh understandably he's
like [__] and he just like runs out of
the basement right and he does not go
back down in there like for the rest of
the time I guess how old was he he said
he was eight or nine I don't know eight
or nine yeah
something yeah he got spooked yeah he
imagined it I am but it might have been
pretty vivid so he felt he felt it
yeah
yeah so doesn't mean the ghost wasn't
[__] with him though he'll make you
see and imagine he's in that bad house
that I was in for a while
dreaming about [__] starving puppies
in all the pipes
having a weird imagination [__] going on
it's just weird you know might have been
something like that
yeah it could have been
so July of 2001
the house is mostly done even though
Jennifer notes that it's really really
hard to keep contractors there because
nobody wants to work on the house it's
kind of like a Summer Wind situation
where every like everybody knows the
reputation of this house and is creeped
out by it so that she can't really get
anybody to stay there to work on it for
any length of time so she ends up we're
doing a lot of the work herself I guess
now she didn't think that she really
believed any of the [__] like she's like
I didn't know if the rumors were true or
anything like that I didn't really
believe it I thought it was just you
know old wives tales or whatever but she
knew that other people believed it and
that was kind of like affecting the [__]
you know what I'm saying
however uh she did note that around this
time she started hearing uh footsteps
like walking around upstairs like in the
middle of the night
so on one occasion apparently she goes
uh to check on Andrew like thinking
maybe it's the kid like you know farting
around up there in the middle of the
night uh so she goes in there to check
on him
and he's fine he's sleeping and she's
just like oh you know whatever and she
just like leaves the room now here's
another thing that they did when they do
this a lot on this show
so she turns around and leaves the kid
is sleeping so obviously nobody could
have seen this so they just put it in
there for a dramatic effect but they put
the the ghost guy who will feature
largely in the episode going forward
um you know the creepy guy with the
Derby that uh Andrew saw on the window
previously puts him in the room like
standing by the window like looking
creepily like at the kid while he's
sleeping but like I said I will note
that nobody said they saw that they just
put that in there just to be scary so
there's that
so late summer of 2001
um again like uh Jennifer and Andrew are
have been in the house themselves
because Norman is like I said away it
works still
and at this point Andrew has one of his
friends whose name is Cody and I will
note that is this the same Cody that was
on demon child I think not the one that
peed in the closet because man said he
could yeah because I was like that kid's
name was Cody too wouldn't that be funny
if they just both they happen to be your
friends man said it was okay
man said it was okay I could come over
this other one yeah
but yeah
so Andrew has this other other Cody
non-demon child Cody over for a
sleepover say the house now Cody is like
walking out and he sees a guy
standing at the top of the stairs it's
the creepy dude with the with the Derby
and whatnot and then Cody like kind of
freezes as you would and so Andrew goes
over there and he sees the guy too
now what they start doing is that he
kind of starts he turns the light on and
the ghost disappears right and they're
just like what the [__] and then they
turn the light off and then he comes
back like he's still there like with the
laid off so they go off on off off and
he keeps like and then like I think the
third or fourth time like when he turns
the light off the ghost isn't there
anymore and then he's like oh I guess
he's gone like who the [__] was that and
then like he turns the light on again
and then off again and then blah like
the ghost is he like right there you
know what I mean like and that I really
liked the makeup job they did on that
ghost because he was actually for real
like creepy looking yeah I remember that
one like he had little kind of Popeyes
you know what I mean he was like he was
an old old but he was like just like an
old like kind of cadaverous looking dude
with like these big I think it was a
creepy eyes 60s maybe it was kind of
hard to tell like with all the makeup on
him and like I said he looked all kind
of like you know turn of the century
like with that kind of like Derby hat on
or whatever or whatever it's not a derby
but it's a hat like that you know what I
mean like with a round top
was it maybe it was a bowler hat it's
not a Hamburg is it I don't know but um
yeah I just I don't know why I know the
names of all these different kind of
hats but
Laurel and Hardy would wear yeah I guess
so I guess so but yeah so that was a
good scene where like the two little
boys were like turning the light off and
on and then sometimes it goes to be
there and then sometimes not and then
they turn off the light and things like
oh he's gone and then he's like right
there in their face and they're like ah
you know what I mean that was pretty
awesome
um and then Andrew growing up Andrew he
says well Cody never talked to me again
after that which like I said again not a
surprise now Andrew does not tell his
mom about any of the stuff that's going
on because I guess he didn't really want
her to worry about it
now in September of 2001 the renovations
have been completely finished and it
turns out that all of the other Busy
Bodies all these nosy Parkers uh in
[__] Garden Grove Iowa I always want
to say Illinois but it's not its Highway
all these other people find out that all
the renovations are done and they want
to come by and see the house absolutely
not shy about showing up in the house
being like hey I heard you remember at
the house you can we troop through here
you know what I mean it's just that kind
of situation I'd be like uh no this is
my [__] house piss off but um but you
know they're a lot nicer than me I guess
so they said okay well we're gonna do an
open house so everybody in the town can
come through and see the renovations
because I guess they did it like back to
how it was back in the old days
so one of the ladies that turns up
to the open house is this older lady and
she says that she's the great niece of
the dude who built the house
and another thing she says which I would
think was kind of creepy I don't know
what her tone was when she said it but
she says oh
um you know the my great uncle or
whoever
he would be very happy to see a child
growing up here
but I'm like I don't know that sounds
like kind of creepy to me if like some
random old lady you didn't know like
said that while they were looking at
your eight or nine year old son I'd be
like get the [__] out right now
um but yeah
so I guess Jennifer was not alarmed
now she ends up giving Jennifer a
scrapbook
and show his pictures of the owners and
the guy who's in the picture who was the
banker that built the house
um
is clearly the same because you know the
kid sees it Andrew sees the picture and
he just like he doesn't tell me he's
like holy [__] that's the ghost I saw
he's just there and he just had a comic
book in his hand he just drops it and
then he's just like
um I gotta go do some [__] bye you know
what I mean because he like wigs out and
they're just like I wonder what that was
all about you know but he's like yeah it
was clearly like the same person
now the old lady says because Jennifer
maybe I mean I guess she wanted to know
I've been there's really no
there's no good way of kind of um
broaching this situation I get this this
topic but she says to the great knees
she says oh well you've heard the rumors
around around town right like about your
relative who supposedly killed somebody
and all the old ladies said was oh well
you shouldn't believe rumors so like I
said I don't know if the shit's true or
not maybe she was just didn't want to
know about it I don't know
but um one thing that the old that the
old lady said
is that the banker that built the house
and the and his wife
had always really wanted children but
they were never able to have any and
they said that the nursery is like right
next to the master bedroom because they
were planning on having kids but it
never worked out for whatever reason and
they were like really upset about it
which is one of the reasons I guess that
the old lady said oh it's nice that
there's a kid growing up in here because
you know they they would have liked that
now Andrew again he still doesn't tell
his mom like he doesn't say that picture
is totally like the ghost that I've seen
several times like he didn't say
anything to her
so there's one scene where he's in his
room playing with some Duplo blocks you
know what I mean and then there's like a
rocking chair like a wicker rocking
chair in his room and it starts rocking
by itself
like behind him
so Andrew you're like very slowly like
turns around to look which I don't think
I would I'd just be like yep I'm out bye
and I just run out of the room without
looking but he didn't he turned around
and look and he sees a woman sitting in
the chair who looks like rolled
distraught
just kind of rocking
so at this point he's like yeah I don't
I don't really want to hang out in the
house too much anymore so when he
doesn't have to be in the house he just
goes and plays in the park and plays out
in the yard [__] like that this is
freaking him out
so Norman uh who is still away at work
at this point
Ashley has no idea like what's going on
in this house because they don't tell
him anything because they're like you
know he's far away what the [__] is he
gonna do and we don't want him to worry
about us and all this other kind of [__]
now
at this point like Jennifer is in her
room and uh after
Andrew saw the lady ghost in his room he
decides he's finally gonna tell his mom
so he runs in there and he's like I just
saw like a lady she was sitting in the
rocking chair like in my room and it's
like really freaky
and then Jennifer was like well she
didn't she's like I didn't know if I
really believed him I thought he was
like maybe imagine it or something but
she was like I was trying to make him
feel better so I was kind of like well
maybe the ghosts are friendly you know
maybe they just wanted a kid and they
never had one so they're just like kind
of hanging out like watching over you
it's fine uh you know they won't hurt
you or anything like that so you know I
don't know but she was just trying to
make the kid feel better
January of 2002.
at this point
um Norman has been away I guess he's
been away for seven months I don't know
if he was away for like a solid seven
months or if he came back and forth but
it had been seven months since he went
away so he came home for a little while
like while he was between jobs or
whatever and again they didn't really
tell him what was going on
however
uh I guess the first night he's home
like Norman and Jennifer are in the bed
and they both simultaneously levitate
off the bed at the same time like whoop
like that which
Norman is like what the [__] which is
yeah what you would because he was not
primed for this at all like Jennifer
didn't say hey I think our shit's
haunted or anything like that I don't
think Jennifer is releasing anything
she's just like heard footsteps and
whatnot but she hasn't really seen
anything that you know that doesn't have
like plausible deniability behind it the
kid is mostly who's been seeing stuff at
this point levitating two adults off a
bed like that without warning
that's that's very rare
that's something to be very rare that's
pretty crazy that would be like and the
Poltergeist scene that would be like
a huge event
very rarely does a conscious person get
moved by by whatever force it is
and I've never heard of it in a haunting
not when not a haunting they had a
credible investigators involved with it
if there are any credible investigators
anymore though I think we know the best
one I want you to be Steve Mara yeah
because you know
um he's open to things but he he's a
little level-headed I don't he doesn't
make anything up not that I've seen
I've just that's a that's quite a claim
it is and it's weird I think this might
be the only case that had that because
and now I'm not saying that they haven't
had other cases on here before where one
person levitated but two of them
simultaneously that's kind of a tall
order yeah that's an unusual it's an
unusually it's an unusual phenomenon
I've never heard that
heard that not in this context
yeah like I said it's very it's what I
don't want to say it's really common but
it's kind of common in these cases for
like one person to levitate yeah well
Janet the little girl from the Enfield
Poltergeist case was seen to supposedly
be levitating
off of her bed by a crossing guard I
think that was standing down on the
street he could see her
um from where she was standing he saw
her go up and kind of hang there in the
window for a second and then come back
down
although
and that case was seen by police it's
well documented we had the book here
it's called this house is haunted
written by Guy lion Playfair and it's
very much like what happened to me and
my family
um just not quite as dramatic as that
one did have a voices or anything
um
now later on somebody said that no
that's not possible because she wouldn't
have been able to see that from where
that Crossing I think it was a crossing
guard
so you got to kind of be there
some people you know what I mean to know
the truth
in a lot of cases even in good cases
you'll have people lie and say that they
saw something that was not possible
you know
um well the thing about it too is that I
they might not necessarily be lying
deliberately they might have seen
something weird and then remember and
then remembered it weirder like when
they thought back up they kept like
exaggerating it Without Really meaning
yeah like that's pretty common in in our
book Lois told us over the phone that
she saw a damn twist tie from a bag of
bread you know with the wax on it jump
up and write the write the word go on
the on the on the window and I know that
didn't happen
and she just remembered it that way
because I found that twist tie
right in front of the window on the
ground and picked it up and as I looked
out the window to where the car was
parked I saw in wax the the word go and
that and I had that little twist tie
that came from the kitchen and I
smeared it along the glass it was the
same thing it wrote go using the twist
tie off a bag of bread
I found it it was on the ground it had
already been written and and Lois hadn't
even been upstairs yet I told them about
it and she came and saw it but she
didn't remember it that way yeah
but see that's just not lying it's just
that's the way she remembered it that's
right no Lewis that didn't happen
because I found it like that's what I'm
saying had already been done and that's
kind of why I'm always like one real
skeptical of a lot of paranormal cases
because and I mentioned that in a book
because most of them come down to you
know people's just testimony which can
be and like I said they might not even
be deliberately lying they might just be
remembering things wrong or whatever or
it got exaggerated in their mind yeah
and um that's also why I don't think you
should ever just take like witness
statements as like the only thing like
in a crime case or something like that
because people can be mistaken without
even really meaning to me you know
because your people's brains are
imperfect and I remembered something
wrong that they corrected me on I
remembered that the first object that
moved was a lamp and I remember the lamp
being like a like a like a teal colored
lamp that was a reproduction of three
um
logs lashed together
with a with a damn life preserver
hanging on it with the lampshade above
it kind of like something you see on the
end of a dock all right
and they told me I was wrong that that
wasn't the lamp that moved the lamp that
moved actually was a black wax lamp that
they used to have in the 70s that they
can make these weird shapes spray it
with a clear with acrylic and it would
freeze like that yeah and and as soon as
they described the lamp and went oh yeah
yeah I remember that laugh
that both of those lamps existed I just
forgot which one it was that moved yeah
but I swore it was the one with the life
preserver yeah that's not that crazy
though because both of those lamps were
in the place you just forgot which one
now thinks they pulled out a photograph
of it didn't they
oh or did I just remember it in my head
I remember what it looked like they said
I don't it was black and brown and I
don't remember seeing a picture of it
okay then I just remembered it from
memory because I was only about 14 I
think 13 13.
yeah so so I don't really know but yeah
so these two
supposedly allegedly
um levitated out of bed at the same time
now Norman I think he has because he was
being interviewed on the thing too and
he said that he also saw what he
described as like a black entity I guess
like in the corner of the room or
something like that when it happened so
as you can imagine he was a little
alarmed
um by this and then at this point
Jennifer tells him oh by the way
yeah we think the house is haunted like
Andrew's been seeing all kind of stuff
and
um Norman got really really mad
um because he's like why didn't you tell
me that any of this was going on but
here's the thing if they had told him
like while he was in Arizona working
he'd just been like oh whatever you're
crazy or you're imagining because that's
what they always do you know what I mean
so it's like would it have done any good
like to tell him probably not yeah I'm
just saying but yeah he got mad and then
he just goes like and he just like
starts a fight what you want to pack up
and leave then and she's like no I don't
want to leave I love this house but
she's like we didn't really want to tell
you you weren't hearing bloody blah
um but he's like well then there's
nothing else to talk about and then he
just like slams out of the room like
well gosh that was real helpful thank
you so much for that
um but yeah now as the time goes on I
don't know like how long it was that he
was home because like I said it was in
between like his work gigs or whatever
so he's home for a little while and as
the time went on like he started to
think like he didn't like being in the
house anymore he said he felt like he
was not alone ever and he felt unwelcome
as though there was something in the
house that was making him feel like it
didn't want him there
um also something lurking in the
basement or you heard something down in
the basement and he goes down in there
and that light starts flickering again
he said he had the heebie-jeebies about
it and then he like was looking around
with the flashlight and then the
flashlight inexplicably went out and
then he saw that big black entity again
like in the corner like like coming up
out of the corner like a big [__]
demon or like smoke demon or some [__]
which was actually like pretty cool I
like that effect too but it was kind of
like the same thing that he saw in the
bedroom apparently so far I would say
that Steve Merritt would call this a
interactive haunting is that what is
that I think interactive haunting I
think a haunting that can actually kind
of respond and interact and it's gives
you weird feelings kind of like the like
a bad house which I had experience with
that
um but it moves things like a
poltergeist
yeah including people I think he called
I think he called that an interactive
awning
I think yeah yeah I had to go back and
look at his what he wrote
but yeah so how to classify it based on
what they're reporting so far
yeah
so it's because it's got
apparitions and you don't you normally
don't see apparitions in Poltergeist
but you do in haunting
it's an interesting case but it's also a
mess the way it's being told to us in
this in this episode although it's
theatrical and it's a good episode it's
hard to keep [__] straight
and you're not sure what what was
actually seen and reported or what
they're just showing you because they're
showing you ghosts and there's no
witness there saying what goes they saw
or what it looked like what are you
doing pook we'll try to get underneath
the damn black what are you doing trying
to get underneath the uh the drop cloth
you should have seen her the other day
we I had the um we were streaming on
Saturday night and like on the floor and
I had the mouse pad this mouse pad up
here it looks like a Ouija board and I
had it on the floor like so I could you
know reach it and stuff and this little
kitty
spent ages and ages trying to crawl
underneath the mouse pad the mouse pad
it's only this big yeah it's a mouse pad
yeah and she's just like sitting there
going what's pretty though and it looks
it looks like it looks like a carpet
she's trying to like tunnel underneath
it and I'm like what the [__] are you
doing she's trying to go underneath the
damn bathroom
um rug like a shower rug try to get
underneath there and she was underneath
it but you can see a big hop and she was
surprised that you could we could see
her I think I have the video that I
don't remember if I put it up on YouTube
shorts or not no I didn't yeah but yeah
or actually I might have put it up on
YouTube it's old like it's from our old
house but I just found her like that I
walked past the bathroom and she's like
underneath the bathroom right you can
clearly see her yeah I mean she wasn't
hiding it's only three and a half feet
by maybe two feet and she's just like
sitting there under it like that and
like I think she thought she was hiding
because she was very surprised when I
was like hey pookie what you doing and
she's like what what do you mean she's
like you can see me
I thought I was hitting
she likes to like climb on herself
because sometimes she'll come in the
room and you'll find like her front half
is like underneath
the throw rug and then like her little
butt is just sticking out the back you
know what I mean yeah she can't see you
so you can't see her right so I think
she thinks she's not even though her
butt is very clearly sticking out from
underneath the carpet it's hilarious
she's like but her trying to climb
underneath the underneath that mouse pad
that was just I'm just like looking at
her going oh my God what are you doing
because it's so small she wouldn't fit
under there yeah she tried though yeah
she did
so uh so yeah so when this all this was
happening like Norman they're trying to
imply I guess that I don't know if I
want to say it was possession but I
guess they were trying to like imply
that whatever this dark entity was that
was in the house was kind of like
influencing him or something so this is
happening like around the fall of 2003
they said so Norman starts acting
apparently like even more of a douche
than usual
so he's getting like real agitated and
real Sullen and real angry just like
Cranky Pants all the time and also they
said that the manifestations got worse
although they didn't really elaborate on
that all too much I'm guessing they're
saying like they saw more [__] or
whatever
so that happens for a while and I guess
it got so bad and he was just being
um you know such a [__] [__] stick
that um when he left again for a few
weeks like for another work assignment
uh they said that
um Jennifer and Andrew were like we were
relieved that he was leaving
because he just kept [__] starting
fights and like yelling and screaming at
everybody and he was just like you know
he just wasn't any fun to be around
so they were actually relieved when he
like went back to work they're like yeah
pissed off holy crap you're making our
lives miserable but yeah so they're like
I said they were trying to imply I guess
that whatever the spirit was in the
house was making him act that way you
know what I mean
I mean so while he's gone still I'm
thinking
um
Jennifer and Andrew they came home from
church one day
and the answering machine is blinking
like there's a message on it
but evidently the answering machine was
not plugged in so even though so it's
not plugged in but like all the lights
are on and the light is blinking like
it's like there's a message on it so
Jennifer's like I don't really know why
I did this but I decided I was going to
push the play button which I don't know
if I would do that or well I don't know
I think curiosity would probably get the
better of me so I'd probably push play
too but it's you know it's no good is
going to come with it you know that I've
seen horror not an haunted house I know
I know it's gonna happen yeah so
so she does she pushes the play message
button and she said there's kind of like
this inhuman noise and then a voice
saying guess what just like Amityville
Horror get out just like that so I was
just like oh it's the Amityville house
calling hold on let me say something
what's that
if you guys would help out the channel
go ahead and hit that like button please
and if you're listening to the show
recorded please remember that we have
super thanks activated
super thank you super thanks that way
it's not just thanks it's super thanks
it's not a regular thanks
[Laughter]
super thanks
sure
but yeah so after the Amityville house
calls them
um
apparently this part was actually kind
of funny we had a good time with this
Jennifer decides she doesn't get a
priest which I thought was kind of odd
so she goes to her church and they get a
bunch of parishioners from the church
which didn't that include the priest I
guess so but it looked like a bunch of
passioners though yeah he would show up
they're gonna come and do a blessing in
the house
so they they all go do you know what I'm
talking about yeah well if they're gonna
do a blessing that's kind of like they
have exorcism type thing he there's a
chance that maybe he didn't want
anything to do with it that's what I'm
saying so I think they just got he's
just like yeah we'll do it yeah because
he's like he showed up religious
vigilance
well I really liked the main guy that
was kind of like the main guy that was
doing the [__] yeah man the actor that
was that he was like really good because
holy [__] he was like [__] committed
to that oh the black dude yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah he was good he was super
into it he was throwing it down he was
you get the [__] out of this house so
yeah that was the priest though wouldn't
it see I don't know because she said
parishioners I get dressed as a Baptist
Minister oh was he yeah I didn't I was
looking down like right now it is nuts
man he was for real but then he's like
let's get the [__] out of here
before he left well because they went
down in the basement and like you know
they said the basement was like super
creepy and [__] like that so so as as
awesome as he sounded and he was all
just kind of like you got out of this
house and blah blah but then like I said
like wind starts blowing and the lights
start flickering then it was like whoop
let's get out of here [__] this yeah
yeah bless bless bless all right bye
yeah it was kind of like that kind of
thing yeah well no he didn't
he did his [__] and then once it was
over he's like let's get the [__] but
during the time he was doing his [__]
the the actor that's portraying him is
actually doing his best Max von Seidel
you know the power of Christ compels
yeah he was really doing all that he was
really into it he was doing it [__]
Southern Baptist style yeah it's good I
liked that that was one of the
highlights of that episode for me I was
like that actor's awesome I love him
yeah um but yeah that's the only time
you've seen him
well maybe in real life the dude was
black so that they had to get a black
dude to play him and you know what I
mean they just never have a call for a
black priest again yeah maybe not dude
dropped his nuts man Max von side out
style I mean if I was a demon I'd
probably leave if he told me to he was
very authoritative
but um you know what I mean uh so so I
guess like the parishioners didn't like
after they did the blessing I guess
Jennifer like asked him well how'd it go
and we don't
it was like that kind of situation
situation uh in my notes I wrote did the
blessing work nah it never does it never
does
um and apparently it's I don't know if
it got worse but it didn't really get
any better
because not too long after this uh I
guess Jennifer and Andrew are in the
house and she hears like heavy footsteps
and then she goes out in the hall and
sees like a figure like walking by the
door
and down the hall
and so she follows it which I was like
well that was Brave of you I don't know
if I'd be doing that I think it'd be
like hiding in the [__] closet or
something now Jan said that you know the
blessings never work let me back up a
little bit in this series throughout the
entire Seasons that we've seen there's a
pattern there tends to be a pattern with
these stories there's a [__] goes down
paranormal [__] happens
there's a blessing
it's calm for a day or two then that
[__] comes back with a [__]
Vengeance and is pissed off then they
gotta have a second blessing that's like
a damn exorcism like the first one
didn't take the first one wasn't quite
good enough so you gotta have to get you
have to [__] go big bore with it you
know you got to upgrade and then that
takes care of it long enough for you to
get the [__] out
or it kind of takes care of it you stay
in the house and you're scared that's
going to come back that's the pattern
yes generally
so yeah
when you're watching a haunting and they
come to bless the [__]
you can bet that it's not gonna you know
and you can also look how much time's
left
but you know it's not going to work it's
only 20 minutes in so you know this
isn't gonna work this time they're gonna
have to call they're gonna have to call
out the big guns now there's something
to be said with that
the Poltergeist event that [__] me
and my family went through if you went
in there and tried to bless that place
it was it would it would have would [__]
you it would have got stronger because
it wasn't a demon or a devil it was rspk
you can't exercise the subconscious of a
living person who's got who's got we
haven't seen it we haven't figured out a
way to do that yeah so it'll just rebel
against it
um
it doesn't matter what you do in a
poltergeist case it tends to resolve
itself they only last a few weeks anyway
so
[__] with them [__] with it is
actually you know counterproductive it's
better just let it run its course
now with a haunting
or what they call haunting cases maybe
there's something to bless in the houses
and but see I haven't seen one of those
I haven't seen I was in a bad house too
also another but nothing happened it's
just feelings you know so I don't know
maybe you know I'd have to be there I'd
have to see this [__] myself
it's like a rank it with the other
phenomena that I've seen
I don't know if it's [__]
yeah but I've seen some wild [__] that I
know exists wilder than what a lot
sometimes in some ways wilder than what
some of these shows say and I know that
exists so maybe something like this
exists but I haven't seen it yeah me
neither and a lot of it is subjective
these people see it and then they
describe it in a way that had I seen it
I probably wouldn't have described it
that way
people see things differently
not everybody you know what I mean it
doesn't even matter what it is two
people can witness a crime and the two
witnesses [__] describe the crime in
two different ways and then neither one
of them could have happened right
because memory isn't especially when
you're under stress you don't have time
to really record it in your mind
memory is very fallible
oh yeah big time Big Time it's been
proven yeah that you can't trust
people's memories no and uh and the
longer it goes the more you the worse it
gets Yeah the more you exaggerate the
more you add details yeah big [__]
happened in [__] the Mammoth Mountain
case we were in that I had forgotten all
about Lois and red had to remind me of
it
pretty big events like throwing the
knife the thing through a knife or
rearrange the Hot Wheel cars I forgot
all about that [__]
but as soon as they said everyone oh
yeah yeah yeah I forgot about it you
know so the the the I mean you
remembered a lot of it you remembered a
lot of it but some of it I forgot
because it a lot of [__] happened like
in a compressed time period yeah
so it's not I was [__] scared to
death and it was a long time ago so it's
not surprising that you didn't yeah I
couldn't believe it was happening I
couldn't believe this happened I was in
denial
yeah so it like I said not
understandable and honestly that's why I
think like I said that's why I think you
should never just take like witness
testimony because if somebody Witnesses
a crime that's a very stressful thing to
witness and they might not be seeing
[__] right you know what I mean through
no fault of their own that's just like
human human brains work comments have
been awful quiet is is comment section
working I don't know that's what I mean
I was frozen for 10 15 minutes I know
I'm always kind of like afraid that it's
gonna but it seems like it's still
streaming okay yeah because sometimes
that means that it's gonna like stop
streaming yeah I don't usually have a
problem with that unless it's storming
out and it's not actually not a storm no
it's mostly cloudy it says but it's not
no no T storms which is what it usually
says and we got a green line so it's
yeah yeah it's all right it's a little
green Square
I guess just nobody's talking yeah but
um but yeah so so yeah so she hears
these heavy footsteps she sees this
figure walking by the door and she
follows it and then it goes like around
the corner of the hall and then it comes
back out again and then it turns to look
at her and it's like
I don't know I guess if you saw this in
real life it'd be scary but it's like
it's kind it was kind of silly looking
like on the show because it looked like
it was this big huge demony face thank
you Jeffy art
yeah Tammy said we're just so enthralled
by the story
well that's that's good I hope that's
what it is thanks for the Super Chat
thank you Jeff yard I really do love
those little animated yeah if you guys
can hit the like button please help us
out hit the like but doing a little
calisthenics there yeah that says hey
you want it yeah it's still here just
listening
okay uh so yeah so he turns around and
it reminded me of what was that movie
oh God I can't even remember the name of
it I don't even know why it reminded me
of this but there was a movie back in
the late 80s I want to say that had
Howie Mandel in it where he played like
a monster or a demon or something I just
I don't even know if I saw it I just
remember seeing the [__] VHS cover
but the demon in this like reminded me
of that he just had a blue face and then
I was like holy [__] he's got a big like
Jay Leno chin and he's because he had
like this big one or he looked like Mac
Tonight a little bit didn't he look a
little bit like mac tonight yeah like
has he had kind of one so that's
something it says disconnected okay
weird so it was it disconnected for a
second yeah
okay disconnected now yeah it's back
it's back yeah we had an interruption
yeah we weren't saying anything yeah
exciting
um but yeah so I so I did think he
looked like Mac Tonight a little bit or
like Jay Leno yeah or because his face
was blue and he had this big [__]
Bruce Campbell situation like going on
down here with the big Shannon [__] and
then like he had red eyes right yeah and
I'd be like I don't know like if I yeah
I'd probably [__] my pants if I saw that
like in real life but it's just like I
don't know thinking about it'd be like
I don't know if you're a demon you want
to be scared so like I said I feel like
you should probably look scarier than
that so since double play looking like J
like Blue Jay Leno like all up in my
house but yeah so there was that
and apparently from this
I guess that Jennifer she said something
to the effect of oh well I guess this
demon or entity or whatever it is they
didn't really say it was a demon did
they they just kind of said no entity
yeah yeah but um
they she said that um oh I guess it can
like manifest however it wants to like I
guess it like it knows what scares you
or something so I guess she was
particularly scared of like big blue
demon dudes that look like Jay Leno I
don't know so that's what it showed her
I don't know
and then of evidently Andrew then saw it
in his room
um he said it was like a huge black
shape like this big black form and he
called it a Batman not like Batman you
know what I mean like [__] Bruce
Wayne but like a bat man that or maybe
like bat boy they're like bad boy but
like a big dude that was like a bat
maybe I was kind of picturing when he
said that I was kind of picturing you
know like Gary Oldman in the in the
Dracula the Francis Ford Coppola Dracula
where he was kind of like half and his
human and half in his Bat form like a
Man-Bat like that's kind of what I was
thinking that he was describing but I
don't know that's not really what the
reenactment looked like but that's what
I was picturing so he said he saw that
in his room and the thing like came at
him like whoa it was like coming at him
like all scary and [__] like that and
you know he's an eight or nine year old
kid so obviously he screams his [__]
head off as again as you would
so Jennifer is just kind of like oh well
whatever that [__] demony thing is
that [__] up there in the kids
room now so she runs up there and at
this point she is just at the end of her
she has had enough she's like she didn't
have any shoes on they both had like
jammies on because they were both in
their in bed or whatever and she just
like she's like I just picked the kid up
if we didn't pick up anything we didn't
take anything we just like took the
[__] car keys and we're just like bye
and they just like ran the [__] out of
the house and bare feet and everything
um so you know I I guess it was pretty
scary whatever happened it's like
getting attacked by a man bat you know
yeah that's pretty terrifying so they
ran out the house
and drive off and she says that even
when they were in the car she was too
scared to look in the back seat or look
in the rearview mirror because she was
afraid that that thing would be back
there like looking at them because she
could like still feel it like around you
know what I mean
so yeah so they got the [__] out and
she's like yeah we need to move the [__]
out of here so in November thank you
in November of 2004 they actually put
the house up for sale
because that was the final straw again
the kid getting attacked by a Man-Bat
but you know what I mean
um and at this point like Norman was
like yeah it's like it kind of sucked
and it was a big pain in the ass and
everything but I was glad they got rid
of it like when he's like after we moved
to another house like a smaller house
everything went back to normal and like
[__] was better and everything like that
and apparently whatever this [__]
thing was like didn't follow them now
Jennifer said that even she still was
like really obsessed with the house
though and she kept like driving past it
and whatnot
she said like five years after they
moved out she actually got up the
courage to like go back to the house and
like knock on the door because she
wanted to talk to new owners to see if
they had seen anything but apparently
nobody answered the door I don't know if
that meant that just like no one was
living in the house or just no one was
home at the time or whatever but they
made it kind of seem like all mysterious
but I don't know how that was but I
think that was pretty much the end of it
right yeah that was like pretty much the
end of it so what did you think about
that the house haunted by Blue Jay Leto
and a big man bat which might be the
same thing yeah like I said because
didn't she say that she thought that it
could you're covering up our light there
oh [__]
I mean I don't know if that light's
really making I think it does
you know we have so many others so many
other lights it's not well what the hell
happened with this
and this
that don't know
there you go that's just falling okay we
will find a new place for that yeah it
just didn't make any sense I mean well
yeah but it's like I kind of I run out
of room to put some in here because you
know
um not a lot of room what do I say about
this yeah
like I said I've never seen
this kind of Haunting I've never seen a
hot straight on [__] like interactive
or demonic type haunting I've never seen
one me neither
um it's a mixture of a lot of phenomenon
that doesn't doesn't match if you're
talking about a poltergeist case
like for instance
Poltergeist which I've seen
is mostly about moving objects
it's not about making apparitions though
the closest thing to an apparition we
saw was like
an occasional blue haze
would be in another room
when you walk up on it it kind of Fades
you can't see it when you get close to
it or when you look directly at it
or you'd see that same blue haze in a
ball shape it'd be up in a corner of a
room
it's kind of blue but it's also kind of
clear and when you look directly at it
you don't see it but if you look to the
side of it you can kind of see it you'd
have you had the Sensation that you're
being watched from there
me and red were like you see that yeah
yeah there's something there you know
what I mean [__] you gotta look to
the side right yeah yeah yeah yeah
almost kind of like a a monkey wave or
what you would call like a heat wave off
the top of a road kind of like that
mixed with something like when you rub
your eyes you see like little lights in
when you're like it's like that up there
and then we'd go like it's gone you're
like yeah it's not there anymore
you know so
I don't know
but I've never seen anything that was a
humanoid object or human like a or a
humanoid what you call apparition
I'd be curious to know if anybody in the
comments had ever seen yeah an
apparition because I've never seen one
either I'm not really sure I'd want to
see one it's like as cool as it would be
probably I'd you know I don't want to be
like getting up in the middle of night
to go to the bathroom and seeing like
some [__] standing under the end
of the hall Lois said it touched her
I saw it touch her I saw I saw it when
she said it touched her red was standing
on the other side of her
she said it felt like
this big snake like a boa constrictor
wrap around her waist
and then rap and she said it felt like
it had a hand on the end of it but I
didn't see anything I just thought I'd
go whoa whoa whoa whoa it wrapped around
her waist and then went down her thigh
and wrapped around her thigh and her and
her knee and then she said she it felt
like it went into the floor and it was
long
you know
four or five feet long with a hand on
the end of it and she just said it felt
like pressure it was kind of cold
kind of like a cold tingly
feeling because it touched me she was
all creeped out oh it was terrible
wow then she started giggling laughing
you know you know it was just kind of
like the what else are you gonna do yeah
and had just thrown some pillows off of
bed and threw them over their heads I
didn't see that they saw that
that's what happened before before that
I ran in I heard I heard him screaming
her Lois screaming and heard that man
did you see that see that and the the
and I ran into the room and saw them
standing at the foot of the bed with uh
the comforter wrapped around their feet
like wind had blown it there and and red
was going like pointing towards the top
of the closet over the top of the closet
there's a space up there an empty space
and I could see the throw pillows the
square throw pillows up there
and I said what happened he was it threw
the pillows and then Lois goes the the
comforter just came off the top of the
bed like it was a manta ray and wrapped
around us and then as she was telling me
that she goes what's got me got me no
[__] she said it she felt it go
around her waist and then around her leg
and down
yeah that's pretty I could see her
jumping like like it was creamy and I
was just like I knew it happened because
other [__] had just been happening
before and I was looking I could see the
little tips of those Square pillows
poking out
over the over the little cubby hole
above the closet
I was just looking there going [__]
that's weird because they flew up
because yeah they flew up over our heads
and I was looking at the [__]
um
comforter
it was around I I was just saying I
didn't really want to accept it but
weird [__] had just happened you know
before and after so I knew it happened
but I didn't see it
yeah it was weird
Tammy said I've never seen anything but
my mom swears she saw her grandmother
after she died she would see her
standing at the foot of her bed there's
a lot of that I've heard of a lot of
people saying that but um well speaking
of apparitions didn't you when you were
in that motorcycle accident didn't your
mom
say that she saw you an apparition of me
an apparition of you yeah before she
knew that you'd been in an accident
that's what she said yeah because she
was in Brazil at the time right yeah so
you were like in two different kinds
yeah so she was already trying to make
phone calls to see if I was okay
yeah and that was supposedly before she
knew that she said she saw you standing
in the kitchen I was in the kitchen
looking and said hi Bob and that she
immediately knew that you weren't really
there and that something yeah yeah yeah
and so she knew something that happened
like she thought you were dead or
something yeah
so she called and then they said yes
that you were in a car then yeah and
that you were in a coma yeah I don't
remember it though well yeah but I'm
just saying that I remember her telling
me that I was having out I was having a
near-death experience I was up in heaven
[__] talking to people yeah I did we
did a show on it yeah the whole
Entourage was there to meet me
yeah I've never seen an apparition
either the closest I've ever come to
that was when I lived um here in Orlando
like in an apartment by myself
I woke up in the middle of the night and
saw a person
standing in the doorway with a baseball
bat
but the weird thing about it was that I
wasn't scared like it was weird and I
was kind of like huh but I because I
kind of knew
I said I think this is sleep paralysis I
thought it was sleep paralysis and I've
never had it before since I think that
was the only time but for whatever
reason like I wasn't scared like oh like
holy [__] it's a real person which is
probably what you would think because
it's like oh oh my God there's a real
person like broke in here because it
wasn't the best neighborhood so I mean
it wouldn't have been that surprising
like did somebody broke in there but for
whatever it wasn't a real person
thankfully but
that was the only time I mean it very
well could have been an apparition I
guess but I just saw it and I just kind
of like thought oh this is sleep
paralysis even though I'd never had it
before so I wasn't like wigging out I
was wigged out for a second because I
was like what the [__] but then I was
like oh I guess it's all right
then I just like went back to sleep you
know what I mean I've had I've had sleep
paralysis too that's the only time I've
ever had a move that's the only thing
you'll see images in there but the thing
is is that I know you I know what that
is and it's not the same as Obe it's the
Obe and nde is a lot different a lot
better
but when I was in sleep paralysis
I I had the feeling that I could go out
of body if I wanted to then I could
shift it like it's only one channel over
but then thinking about it too much and
trying and trying to just leave
and to become exteriorized
can cause you to wake up
yeah and when you're when you wake up
out of the then you can't do it
Jeff yard said my mom said she saw my
deceased great-grandfather walking down
the hall to my crib a few days after I
was born at first she was scared that he
had come to take me oh [__] all right if
he if she saw it then he was there to
see you I mean I guess look at it yeah
you want to look at the baby
then Tammy said I used to get that a lot
in high school sleep paralysis you never
knew what it was until recently yeah
it's like um I have a friend that has it
like pretty bad but
and she's told me like some horrifying
[__] yeah she's seen but um I've only
had it that one time and it didn't alarm
me like for a second I was just kind of
like wait what because you know but then
I was like oh this is probably sleep
Frozen I don't like to use paranormal
terminology because it's too confusing
and there's a lot of crack Pottery in it
so I I kind of like to use Star Wars
terminology because it's everybody knows
the terms pretty much if you've watched
Star Wars and it's based upon Buddhist
philosophies and some of the German type
philosophies too that have had that were
based on Buddhism
so if I say something I'll use Star Wars
terminology a lot of people understand
what I'm saying especially if they
played video games like
uh what was that one called uh [__]
uh Knights of the Old Republic or Sith
Lords it was a great [__]
games a lot of good voice acting in them
dialogue and [__]
and it all [__] adheres to
very Advanced kind of Buddhist
philosophies
young people have a close a very close
connection with the force sometimes
that'd be a good way to put it
um
the uh it's because their
consciousnesses are not
tainted
by mundane ideas so in other words there
are a lot more free thinking and they
don't really know the rules so they're
able to break rules a lot better
because the world is a manifestation
of your will and your idea that'd be a
good way to Arthur schopenhauer would
say reality is what you think it is a
lot of times
doesn't mean you can always do things
like jump out of a window over 20 story
building and fly that's not gonna happen
it's just that your perception has a lot
to do with your state of mind
all right and sometimes Altered States
of perception can impact
physical reality
to a certain extent move objects
um
remote knowledge you can know what
somebody else is doing when they're far
away you can dream true
you can contact another sleeping person
in their dreams like from Dreamscape
just it's not quite as intense as that
I've done it before
I've also had girlfriends that could do
it to me
Stephanie could do it and it was weird
because she I'd be dreaming and I could
see her and she tried to pull me out of
the dream
but it would [__] me up and wake me up
and then I thought I just dreamed it was
[__] and then she I saw you in a
dream she'd be sleeping next to us when
we lived together
and I said no no because yeah don't you
remember we were on top of that castle
and I was like yeah yeah we were on top
of that castle
so that's some weird [__] because I told
her what had happened to me yeah and and
I
I was reading she got me a book on
astral projection and when I was reading
I was going yeah that's what it felt
like
it was a method of how to exteriorize
and I did that kind of Accidentally In
the barracks because that's it that so
she read it too so she was trying to do
it yeah
and part of that book said that well if
you become conscious in a dream knowing
that you're dreaming you can launch from
there
yeah so we made an agreement that if we
ever came conscious in a dream
to grab the other person
when she tried to grab me I was in a
dream yeah I saw her face in the dream
but I woke up we should try that yeah
yeah the only thing the closest thing
I've had of that is a lot of times I'll
have a dream like that's real [__] up
or something and then I dream I guess I
dream that I tell you about it but then
like when I wake up I can't remember if
I actually told you or if you dreamed or
if I dreamed that I told you well here's
the thing probably I would have known
what you're talking about because maybe
you did tell me that's what I'm saying
so it's like probably I should yeah you
gotta check with you see me and jamming
are [__] tightly tightly woven
together we've been together for 13
years yeah we can [__] drive around
and do things without even talking to
one another and we know what we're
thinking
I know what you're thinking pretty much
all the time yeah you don't have to talk
anymore I mean we still do obviously
we're saying we don't really need to no
no she's thinking yeah yeah yeah well in
the face and we see something I know
exactly what she's thinking I don't even
say anything yeah
well that's the thing I mean I think
people have seen us do it on the live
stream where it's like you'll just be
talking about a random [__] and then you
want to think of like a movie or a
situation or something I know exactly I
know exactly yeah because I know how
your mind works yeah that's not how she
works too so yeah
and like and like I said you know if you
guys if you're new to the show whatever
me and Jim were friends and business
partners before we started a a
relationship
but the thing is is that that was part
of our relationships too yeah we were
dating other people and everything she
was married when I first met her so it's
not a normal relationship but me and Jen
are not normal people
they're not well that's true
we have [__] very unique backgrounds
that come from a very unique scene and
uh we're not like normal people at all I
don't think I've been with a lot of
women Jen has very little in common with
the average woman
which is kind of a good thing I mean
it's in a way it's hard because I have a
hard time
um relating to normal people so if I'm
in an in an environment where I have to
interact with
normal people a lot like it's really
really hard for me it's really hard
dealing with Jin is a lot more like
dealing with a guy not to say that she's
like you know butcher like lesbian or
anything anything like that she's not
she's a little bit Butch she's a little
bit but yeah but that's not really what
it is it's just that she's very
analytical she's a lot like Spock she
ver she's not as emotional as I told you
my ex-husband used to call me spots as
well like disparagingly yeah no and I
was like nah I'll take that as
accomplishment thank you she's very uh
analytical and real
um right-brained
Left Brain yeah there's more yeah real
left brain
foreign
she can come to understanding with a guy
a lot easier than the average woman in
Canada a lot of women you it's I can get
along with them well but
it's not like it's not like talking to a
guy you know what I mean with Jan's kind
of a little bit more like talking to a
guy you can reason with her
and she knows what I'm talking about
she's actually seen me in other
relationships yeah most of them were
good though yeah there's only a couple
of them like I said where they're it's a
more of a regular type girl
like that Disney's Princess yeah that
she goes you get away from that [__]
book
she was right but I was just doing what
guys do they yeah [__] hot girls you
know what I mean I was just hey you know
it's only gonna last a couple weeks the
um
that was a typical woman and they're
difficult to deal with well I find them
difficult to deal with yeah well like I
said I find normal people of all genders
difficult to deal with yeah she was what
they would call in common in the red
pill [__] Community she'd be called a
Stacy that was a Stacy
and uh I could deal with Stacy but I
know if Stacy's a Stacy here now there's
limits with them
they're not they're not very creative
they're not very flexible
um they're very much in the Box thinkers
um they're normies
not a bad thing just not really my thing
yeah I mean a lot of people are normally
a lot of people like I said I'm not I
was gonna say I'm not disparaging I'm
not saying that I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with Nori's I'm just
saying that I have a hard time relating
to them the world could not function
without normies well yeah that's what
I'm saying I'm just saying that because
I'm a [__] weirdo yeah
um I have a hard time
relating to the same like them on the
same level so it's like really
exhausting for me to be around them
that's all like and that's my fault I
guess but they're in the box they're
kind of conformist
and I forget sometimes because it's like
I'm so used to being around you and
being around people who are
not normal in various ways and so I'm
you know I'm just kind of like kind of
free to like be a weirdo and [__] like
that so sometimes I forget that I can't
be a weirdo around like other people
because they get like they're like what
the [__] are you even talking about you
know what I mean I was like you know
what I mean so sometimes I forget and I
think that's what's exhausting is that
I feel like I can't really um
be myself around people like that
because
another thing too that I don't really
like to do the reason that I like to
just kind of hang out with people that
sort of like had the same experience as
me or like have the same interests as me
as because I don't like I'm really
impatient and I really don't like to
have to explain things to people
so it's like if I meet somebody that
doesn't know anything I mean you know
this is like a superficial thing but
it's like if I meet somebody that
doesn't know anything about like horror
movies or something like that and it's
like if I say something about or maybe
like I'm wearing a t-shirt or something
like that and then they like ask me
about it and then now I'm kind of
obligated to go into this big long
[__] discussion and like explanation
about it and I just don't want to do
that because I'm like impatient you know
what I mean I just kind of want to do
like shorthand I want people that know
you know like I said I've thought about
it before because it's like so I'll wear
this necklace sometimes for example and
sometimes people don't know who it is oh
who is that like on your necklace and I
was like it's HP Lovecraft and like some
people don't know who that is and so I'm
like Jesus Christ so I really now have
to explain like who HP Lovecraft is it's
like you know Cthulhu Mythos they don't
know what that is either so then it's
like now I have to go to this big long
[__] history lesson and I'm like you
know you could look this up on the
Internet it's like why are you
why are you obliging me to like stand
here and like give you all of this if
you're interested go look it up yourself
it's like I'm not your like explainer
person so yeah so I'm like I said I'm
really impatient like that and it's like
I would prefer to just hang out with
people who already know who HP Lovecraft
is and we can just like have a shorthand
about it I don't want to have to like
explain [__] to people you know what I
mean it's like it's very tiresome to me
so so there's that issue also
big little says yeah Dave says she a
couple of freaks I know I mean but
you know that's just that's how we roll
that's how we roll I was I was saying
that it's easier for me like to hang out
with people that already know
stuff like you know this the [__] that
we're into because it's like I don't
like to have to explain [__] to people
yeah mostly in in the subculture we come
from they more than half the people kind
of on the same wavelength as us that's
what I mean and you can have like what
we're talking about so you can have like
conversations where you don't have to
like go back and be like oh yeah explain
everything because I was using as an
example and sorry because I'm repeating
this but it's like Tom wasn't here yeah
so I was like you know sometimes I'll be
in a thing like I'll be in a store or
something like that and somebody will
ask me like I'll have this necklace on
and people will ask oh who is that and
I'll say it's HP Lovecraft they don't
know who that is and then so then I have
to like explain it and they don't know
what the Cthulhu Mythos is they don't
know like anything about that so it's
like then I just have to go through this
big long explanation when nowadays you
can just look it up I'm kind of a child
of Two Worlds in a way where I'm [__]
real at home
in our in the gothic subculture we've
been in it forever but there's a lot of
stuff that I like that has nothing to do
with God like I'll you know
being basically raised in a military
academy and having military and
Contracting careers though for those
people know nothing about that at all
you really it's kind of a full pot to
even bring it up
uh so they know they know about me
though
um
but when you're there in a club that's
not that's not the topic that's not
topical so you don't have to worry about
that too much and
um so I can kind of move between
different worlds in the military in law
enforce the world
kind of kind of Normie yeah even though
this is something you know in [__]
Terence pops he has a channel you can
call ridiculous
and he's an xsf guy who was he was uh
basically in charge of Abu garib prison
for a while that he was in the army he
has all kinds of paranormal experiences
there's something about military and
police
guys I think because we're closer to the
animal world and about feelings and
emotion and perception
we tend to and life and death struggles
and seeing death a lot
we have paranormal experiences
even though this [__] isn't exactly as
it seems the spiritual [__] happens and
I guess that goes way back and it goes
back to the [__] Aztecs
you know
[__] Eagle Warriors and [__] they
were taking drugs and having spiritual
spiritual experiences too it was
religious to be to it was
it was a religious status to be
a warrior because they you know
especially in Mesoamerican Indians and
stuff Native American Indians
part of your religious Duty was to take
captives for sacrifice if you were you
know the meshika or the or the Mexico
probably how they're pronounced in
Spanish but uh
you know people don't realize that
cutting somebody's heart out was your
religious duty to have your heart cut
out
all those guys
yeah all those guys had the same
religion take that [__] out had to keep
the had to play back the blood dead
so war was more like a sport for those
guys a religious
sport
so soldiers and cops and [__] like that
have weird experiences a lot
you know paranormal type [__] well
honestly like I listen to a lot of those
kind of scary stories channels then
people send in like they're true
supposedly true like Paranormal some of
them are obviously [__] but a lot of
them are like cop security guards stuff
like that that have like all kind of
weird [__] happens yeah
so
we can say that you know the military
and police profession might seem very
Normy
but no
you're living on at an extreme
a lot of times so this weird [__] Could
Happen even if you're a pilot the
[__] see UFOs I believe them
which that would be paranormal that's
outside what the normal thing would be
they don't see ghosts soldiers see
ghosts
ghosts of the Dead
they just tend to
they're in places where people would be
killed you know
Tammy says telling someone you're an
atheist and you like horror movies and
serial killer documentaries
automatically you're a weirdo yeah
pretty much now I will say that it has
improved a great deal
um when I was in high school in the late
1980s
um if you were
if they saw you like read I I actually
got sent to the guidance counselor's
office several times because some of my
teachers like reported me for like
literally reading horror novels and
wearing black and stuff yeah so I don't
know if that would happen anymore as
long as you weren't doing anything like
super alarming not anymore but um but
back in the 80s for sure like if you
because it wasn't as common satanic
Panic era yeah that was still satanic
panic because I was in high school from
1888 88 89 and 1990. so yeah so I got
reported a couple of times like just for
reading [__] Clive Barker and
listen to goth music and looking like a
weirdo having half my head shaved that
kind of [__] so yeah they would send you
the guy they thought something was a
matter with you so
like I said there weren't that many of
us
back then
but yeah all right so um you ready to
wrap it up it's about yeah it's about
nine o'clock yeah yeah and I get ready
for bed now I gotta get up early [__]
like old people man go to bed at like 9
30. well if I had to give a five if I
didn't have to get up at five in the
morning I wouldn't yeah I feel like I
don't want to go to bed at nine o'clock
I'm on her schedule I go to sleep the
same time
wake up at five o'clock in the morning
yeah but you know it gives you more time
to work on [__] I know but it's like it
kind of sucks though because then when I
come home I'm like so [__] sleepy
yeah that it's like
and I still got [__] I gotta do when I
get home and it's like and I feel like I
started and I was like I don't want to
do it I just want to lay it down the
cutest dress on this is a little Fair
dress actually I have one like this but
it's also like stand up it's like an
adjustable length you can make it long
down to the knee or all the way up to
your ass cheeks hanging out at the
bottom it's got little butterflies and
it's like something out of the damn 90s
backups everybody can see the whole
thing yeah
her little fairy core dress it's like
something out of the 90s yeah it's cute
yeah they have a bunch like this
it's very I guess it's very kind of
there's there's kind of like a a return
to the 90s type of thing yeah it's like
something messy star would wear right or
like I like them though well the one I
have I have this one that has
butterflies on it and then I have one
that's kind of like a dark Dusty Rose
yeah and it has is it skulls yeah is it
skulls skulls and roses I think it has
on it maybe Tammy saying that's pretty
yeah we got that off the sheen app yeah
get that she in app that was like an 11
dress yeah it was super cheap it's super
cheap and it's nice it's like it's
really thick like it's really nice uh
you might have to wait a week to get it
but it's it's
I've been very happy with everything
everything you get from she is
everything is like very good quality and
Washi and just [__] search Gothic and
flavorful dresses and all that [__] I
thought it was going to be like wish and
you would get it and it was like made of
newsprint or something but it's no
everything's like really yeah she said
she's got she in yes off she had got her
a whole new wardrobe for like 250 300
bucks get all this I know I can't
believe it I was like I still have
clothes I haven't worn yet yeah
that's how many [__] clothes that I
got yeah and we didn't even spend that
much and I said yeah I still have like
there's like two pairs of pants I
haven't worn that's like I got a bunch
of tops I have there's a couple dresses
I haven't worn yeah but yeah but yeah I
really do like it we're gonna make
another
purchase yeah we're gonna run it we're
gonna make another run this maybe maybe
next maybe Friday like when I get paid
again yeah but yeah we'll look for some
more stuff because I got a I got a 20
off for a hundred dollar purchase with
free shipping oh well there we go okay
all right we'll just use that so for 80
bucks you can get 100 we'll throw some
stuff in the cart yeah but yeah all
right so like I said
uh on Wednesday we're gonna be doing
another paranormal show we're going to
be talking about the the Demon House
quote unquote uh the Ammons haunting
case interesting case which uh Zach
Bagans
I'm gonna call him jack Baggins I don't
care but um which which he did a
documentary about which is on Amazon
Prime if you want to watch it we watched
it last night
um but yeah it's an interesting case I
wrote about it for my book unseen hand
so I've been wanting to do a show about
it for a while so yeah we're gonna do
one on Wednesday so that should be a lot
of fun
so we will see you guys again on
Wednesday night please have a good rest
of your evening and have a good day
tomorrow and we'll see you then good
night